parla spiega allora inizia il giorno
prima persona ha una faccia diversa può
essere che siamo in questa situazione è
il giorno a casuale possiamo essere o
militari o poliziotti o scienziati o
personale o sc p giochiamo bene a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti che sono io sono
sono sono stato espulso dal server
salvami j siano su sc p è un gioco di
che miasi costato ciccio mi hanno
espulso da serve però questo problema in
gioco dove tu puoi essere oi mostri che
uccidono gli altri o gli altri che
devono scappare o altri enti o altri che
uccidono altri devono scappati non ho
capito una sega dovremo giocare per
capirlo l'unico modo per giocare entra
in un server quindi parlare con la gente
è un gioco dove si parlano gli altri ci
sono sono una volpe a nove code cadetti
io cosa posso fare qua dobbiamo riuscire
a scappare quanto ha detto ciccio
d'emilio se riusciamo a beccare ciccio
ma io a uno zio show figo ma cos'è anni
27 va bene vediamo se riusciamo a
difenderci d'asti mostriciattoli ma
nessun compagno
porcaccia va a cadwell ciccio voglio
parlare con la gente che vogliono far
capire
ok se ne sta parlando a mi sa che c'è un
altoparlante da voi che parte sto tipo
ci sta parlando dal poiché i ragazzi
forse questa e l'altoparlante dal quale
parlava quel tizio ries perché vedo se
riesco a mandare un messaggio a tutti
quanti
viva la pizza avranno sentito tutti
ecco se mi ha sentito sono andato
all'altoparlante di spillo alla pizza
grande e viva la pizza che a lei vicine
e che ho visto nella vita è stato
bellissimo che sei il giorno del mondo
perché non l'ho mai giocato prima è
bellissimo cioè è la cosa più bella che
abbia mai visto c'erano parole la gente
è fantastica perché non sono tutti i
casini morto e guy hands chiave
d'accesso
you were killed by adriano cicinho
leggere in inglese c'è scritto work
station la playstation è bloccata chiama
il manager deve identificare la verità
qualcosa ho cliccato signora sono tuo
manager si affibbia guadagnare un sacco
di soldi a possiamo scegliere vendiamo
le armi al commercio quando selezione fa
centro lontano e bellissime fa morire
per questo sto gioco capito e che si
rimane a perché li sta sparando foro
cristo dobbiamo farcela c'è gente qua
c'è uno che siate frost stiamo
ripartendo rendere starting pd c'era un
re starting giusto sino a sistema dei
licei
non mi ha detto credo malissimo noi
golfo
non ho capito niente di quello che ho
detto ma che sei chiedo io guardo io
think about cristiano ronaldo juventus
che avrebbe preferito non sono di in
cina e oggi l'ha detto mesi e bellissimo
che fai vai che posso giocare ma
centinaia crisi di fare io sono eseguito
da un mazzo attivo anche in pratica o di
un tipo lento aiuto c'è un tipo che
sembrano stato e signori partiti e tu
sei sempre sc p ma basta brad l'acqua
yes yes scaricando sta arrivando
abbiamo quasi giustiziato mi hanno
sparato i miei compagni sono quasi morto
qui quarta volta che che kakà è stato
bruttissimo che succede jobs che era
allucinante si è aperta la porta non
capivo se c'era qualcuno a una certa è
uscito un mostro ma si è entrato mister
no e no no no no no perché c'è un mostro
della scienza possiamo entrare sono
entrato porca vacca di un'auto bianco
cosa vedo tutto bianco sono rimasto solo
nell'ascensore aiuto aiuto o ricavati
aiuto non ci sono non ci sono ci sono ma
sono forte no e ucciso uno ce n'erano
due nascosti nell'ascensore vi sono
sfruttati non ci sono l'ascensore e alla
l'inizio è stato bellissimo mi sono
pagato fortissima mamma ma pure mi ha
detto dammi un bacio che dell'addio
stanno anche lui sono andati in due sono
andati 2 morire stiamo andando pian
piano tutti negli ascensori si aprono e
l'ascensore
c'è qualcuno morto sei sono uscite
ucciderò le scene se ci sono forte da
solo completamente da solo
ora è uscito dall'ascensore mi uccido
porca vacca così successo nostra
possiamo fare ok allora seguiva e dimmi
cosa fare
credo che morirò questo si chiama bene a
questa è la stanza che puoi parlare con
tutti aspetta apri apri
ecco bavaj parla farlo ha detto no way
you are brad will find you e we give you
soon pizza avranno capito reso più nome
della piccola
urca lacca c'è un tipo cinese
sufficiente cp gli ho sparato io non
vedo niente ma che vale non vedo dove
sta andando aiuto anche male ma chi mi
fa male a mi sparano i compagni
porca vacca c'è un mostro
we are friendly pizza vichinghi view to
meet individuo
adesso un pizza light pane pizza di orso
magro unit di pizza if you wait and all
his friends and if you one su pizza ha
detto che non avevo soldi prossimo
ancora vivono you die ed in the pocket
dimensioni tra è stata carina l'idea
della pizza
l'importo la pizza esaurito in italiano
italiano maniera
no le classi di personaggio dei plc
avremmo mai sono stesso gruppo che a noi
è un rapper un rapper una volta se
adriano orange is the new black trovato
siamo certi arancio e sta accendendo uno
dei militari a 1 trovato l'arma però ha
iniziato a sparare mio compagno ha
provato a sparare anche a me rajavi volo
uccidere in uno zaia la r new york las
di persona lì mi chiama giappone
pure io cast di personale che dobbiamo
fare i one direction guardie belli e
siamo oranges di new pizza ora that's
making sisma gli altri raid il perfetto
il ciccio ciccio youtube
lessi scritti da me lies iscritti nel
mito uk kilim più cose is not famous i'm
famous and air one in gerz non mi hanno
più seguito
ok hai visto gli è piaciuto il discorso
degli iscritti mai tra gli riferisci nel
momento del bisogno i 36 st palop in
inglese
ok io sento sento anch'io parlando è il
sottodiciotto sta salendo fin dove i
regali e ma che non c'è l'uscita fa
mista mi spazio a star mo
[Risate]
che bello studio il più è bellissimo ma
cavolo
va bè ragazzi io spero che vi sia
piaciuto mi è piaciuto un sacco giocare
al suo gioco con ciccio che non
conoscevo però è veramente figo è niente
se vi è piaciuto ma sente lasciato come
ti piace questo descrizione passato
anche dal canale di ciccio che mette
iniziare e noi ci vediamo a bari
[Musica]